you may have seen a few of these pop up
on your phone or in your email Google
Facebook Twitter dammuz on square
GoDaddy Tesco Sainsbury's H&M and many
more are updating their policies to give
consumers more control over their
personal data those updates and changes
are thanks to a new law governing data
privacy called the general data
protection regulation or gdpr the catch
is gdpr
only applies to people who live in the
European Union but it's adoption is
largely expected to have Americans
asking why don't we have that here's how
data collection currently works when you
sign up for let's say Facebook you have
to click a box agreeing to the company's
terms those terms give Facebook the
right to track your online activities
even if you're not actively browsing
Facebook Facebook can let third parties
access it in order to sell ads and
services consumers will have the right
to ask the copies of anything as basic
as messages sent to them or by them that
Bloomberg tech editor Nate Langston up
two entire archives of all the content
they've generate sit on the service on
May 25th companies with more than 250
employees and that hold data on European
citizens will have to get unambiguous
consent from users to collect their data
instead of just burying that okay in
size fine print it will also make it
much easier to revoke consent users had
previously given for consumers that do
opt in they have a right to know what's
being done with their data and instead
of being charged to obtain it can
request a free copy for companies like
Google and Facebook they've been making
data available for download and deletion
upon request for quite some time
consumers also have the right to be
forgotten which lets citizens request
that organizations delete their data
data portability that gives consumers
the right to retrieve their data and
sell it to other companies so for
example you may be able to trade
something like a gift certificate from
Zara in exchange for your shopping
history from j.crew if a firm has a date
of reach companies must notify the
authorities within 72 hours and any
failure to comply with this new law will
be costly penalty fines can be as high
as four percent of a company's global
annual revenue Europe expects companies
to act within the spirit of the law and
not just to try and follow it to the
letter
this means there'll be disputes and
legal precedents to be set over the
coming
so while the u.s. is still reeling over
Facebook and the Cambridge analytical
scandal the EU is moving ahead with
tough new rules many will ask if the US
should be next
you